Vernon Smith received a 2002 Nobel
Memorial prize in economic Sciences for
his pioneering work in experimental
economics over the past four or five
years starting under Donald Trump the
federal government has just pumped tons
of money into circulation Joe Biden
recently proposed a 6.8 trillion dollar
budget you know we're experiencing
inflation what is the way out of that
kind of situation I think the first way
out
is for the Central Bank not to
accommodate spend thrifts in government
because it's very hard to keep Democrats
wanting to make the world better by
spending other people's money you know
they're really committed to that and the
Republicans to some extent that's the
second screw-up you're not going to be
same necessarily by them